gentlemen can you tell us all about what
this festival is what we're all doing
here today we've come to celebrate both
this incredible farm mmm what they do
here but also a brand of cannabis or
brand that we've been supporting and get
involved with for a couple of years now
as the date of legalization approaches
and there's a valuable information
people need this is part of the way of
getting the message over it's a cool
time an exciting time and maybe even
that I don't know if it if it was a
scary time or were you guys unsure at
all about about getting involved in this
before the ization was going to be
happening October no we weren't uneasy
to vote it at all we start talking about
it and were approached probably like
three years ago now and we were all
really in favor right from the start
gore Downey in particular was it was a
huge fan of the potential of this you
know it's we've always sort of looked on
it as that the day was sort of
inevitable but it's like being around
that they at the end of prohibition you
know leave yeah so it's really exciting
time sighting times for our society
sighting times for our culture and and
it's really important you know to get
the right information out there's a lot
of people a lot of people are scared
they don't know what's gonna happen and
and and so that we're happy to be on
board and happy to be involved with this
great company and a great bunch of
people you mentioned you know it is like
the end of prohibition and there is a
lot of misinformation out there are
things people are kind of scared of what
are your hopes for the future like for
the immediate future come
you know this fall
well I mean I don't think we have any
sort of ideal vision in mind except that
we are very aware and I think all the up
people are aware and and everyone that
is growing pot and managed to get a
sales license grow license and a sales
license from Health Canada it's there's
a lot of smart people have to figure out
a lot of tricky situations with it so
but we feel like we're a part of
figuring out part of that for people in
that you know go easy that that the
beauty of this situation is that now you
know what you're getting as opposed to
you go to your you know your dealer
before this or you know you don't
necessarily know what you get you're
getting and so it's it's a I think a
very good thing to to actually control
this stuff and I think that's what the
government is doing but there's still a
lot of stuff to be figured out and so
we're we're committed to to up and and
we're enjoying it and we feel like it's
creative and we're you know gonna stress
be cool man um so what attracted you to
to look but what made you want to get
involved in this as you know not just
for for recreational fun best business
venture
well it seems like an incredible
opportunity and we mentioned the end of
prohibition yeah
the Canadian Senate recommended
something like this in 1972 this has
been a logical step for a long time and
a lot of people who had the information
said this is the way we should go this
is it's logical to look this way and a
lot of fear and political pressures and
order concerns and various trade
concerns held held back the progress I
guess all the times here and it's an
exciting opportunity and you know it's
no secret that we like cannabis products
and that's no secret like so many other
people out there and I think that used
responsibly by adults
there's no reason
oh my and one should be told they can't
yeah this bothers a lot of people in the
media especially south of the border to
kind of celebrating Canada's decision
you know to legalize this coming in
October in a way it seems like a very
Canadian and amazing you guys always
been so deeply entrenched in Canadian
culture you know over the course of your
careers I want to ask you guys about
word a bit were you you know given how
entrenched you are how how much people
feel when they think about your music
and they and they have come to see you
what was your reaction to the outpouring
of gratitude and grief from like the
entire country
when Gore passed yeah I mean we weren't
surprised at all to be perfectly honest
we felt it ourselves in a completely
different way and sort of a deeper way
you know we were we've been together for
an awful long time we've always
approached this band as a family and you
know from the days back when we were
young men driving around in a van back
and forth across the country you know
you you get to know each other really
well and it's the right thing about
being a band in Canada I mean that's
what breaks bands up is smelling each
other stinky feet for a 14 hour drive to
Canora but we kind of like each other
stinky feet and we stayed together
through the whole thing and that's why
we're that's why we're involved with
this Gordon was a core there's a big fan
of this this company and and and the
people you know and it's working with
the right people and and these guys add
up they they're not they're not pushing
to be the biggest they're not trying to
buy their way to the top they're they're
developing you know strains five
different strains of marijuana that
we're announcing today that that have a
little bit of something for everybody
you know it's not just about going out
and getting his highs you possibly can
it's you know the opportunity to sit
back and chill out with you you know at
the end of the day after the kids are in
bed and relax a little bit like we all
need to take the edge off every once in
a while and and you know maybe it's time
that we tried something different you
know and and we think about are involved
with with these guys and you know we you
know just when we're all together and
like we're honor and go or do you know
it's a cool thing yeah
you're I'm sure your fanbase in
particular is going to be attracted to
this product are you hoping to bring a
lot of your fans specifically over to
experience with you guys in a way I
don't think necessarily you know I mean
we we love our fans but you know and as
time has moved forward we communicate
much more than we used to with them yeah
but I don't know if they want to smoke
weed I you know I don't necessarily know
that there's a assert other people
disagree that there's a certain you know
sterile stereotypical hip fan but so
yeah I mean you know we're just or were
we've been putting it out there that we
have been working with these people and
they want our input and so it's like
it's a creative outlet for us we
obviously you know don't have what we
used to have with cord around in a band
that was playing and and making music so
this is you know it's a great thing for
us but I don't know that we're kind of
looking sort of you know what the ideal
situation would be there'll be hip fans
that want to try our weed I would guess
you know you mentioned you know these
days being able to be in touch with your
fans more I guess then then at any time
in the past when you're in touch with
them when you're talking with them do
you get anything for them or or a.m. do
they communicate to you that they want
to see you perform music to continue on
as tragedy hit I hear that a lot
yeah
and when I say The Tragically it doesn't
exist as a performing unit anymore
because a key member is gone yeah I
think they understand that you know I
had great respect for Led Zeppelin who
said without John Bonham we're not let's
Ephram algin and the other bands have
continued on without key members and I
think a lot of times there's a lot lost
yeah we would it wouldn't be the episode
would we we work together musically
we've done the thing various things
together on musical fronts collaborated
on projects and you know these guys are
my brothers love them dearly and I know
we will continue to work together
creatively musically and on projects
like this yeah but the hip has played
their last